[APPLAUSE]
MILENA NIKOLIC:
Thank you, Shannon.
Hi, I'm Milena.
I'm an engineering
manager on Google Play.
I lead distribution
and developer
console platform teams.
I'm here to talk to
you about how you can
launch Smart on Google Play.
So Ellie did a great
overview of how
you can develop Smart, and do
well while you are developing.
I'm here to also
tell you a little bit
about what you do when you come
to launching on Google Play.
More specifically, I want to
talk about rapid iteration,
and how you can iterate
your app to higher quality
and to a better market fit
using some of the tools
that we provide in Google
Play Developer Console.
I'm also going to talk about
how you can analyze your app,
how you can experiment
with various things--
both about your app and about
your store listing-- how you
can optimize a number of
different things, how you can
localize, go globally,
and in general just
kind of improve performance
of your app in the Google Play
Store.
We're also going to talk
a little bit about how
you can really listen and hear
what users are telling you
about your app.
And then how you can
interact with them
by addressing their feedback.
And then we're
very briefly going
to touch on how you
can monitor-- how
you can do all this on the go.
And especially how you can
monitor the status of your app
on the go.
So let's start with
launching and iterating.
I wanted to start
with this quote
we got from Michael Ritter,
the SVP of development at SGN.
So they shared his
feedback with us,
why they launched "Genies
and Gems" on Android first.
Basically they told
us that because they
can iterate very
fast in Google Play--
because the publishing
delays are very low
and publishing is
very quick-- they
were able to achieve very
significant business outcomes.
There is more of a quote.
SGNs are very heavy
users of beta testing,
of store listening
experiments-- a number
of different iterations tools
and experimentation tools
that I'll keep referring
to in this talk.
But the interesting
thing was also
that they took a number of
findings from their insights
from experimenting
using our tools,
and then were also able to
apply them to other platforms.
Which is a very efficient
way of doing business.
OK so as I go
through this talk, I
will be referring to various
different stages of launching.
And I suspect many of you
have done this before.
You will you have went
through these steps.
The first one would
be beta testing.
So that's when you have kind
of the core flow of your app.
The core idea of
what you want to do,
but you're still not ready
to go very widely with it.
You want to try it out with
a few friends, family, maybe
employees of your company.
And have some sort of
narrow, narrow audience.
The second step would
be soft launching.
So this is when you
actually want to expose,
you want users to get
their hands on your app.
They want them to
try a few things.
You want them to
actually try to use it
so you can measure some KPIs.
Like are users
returning to your app,
how are daily active users,
how does retention look.
How are these basic KPIs
looking about your app.
At some point you will--
when all of those numbers
look really good, when users
are spending money or spending
time within your app--
you will want to launch.
We will also talk about
what are the tools that
are helpful at that point.
And then we'll also talk
about what happens after that.
After the initial
launch you still
want to keep going in the app.
You want to keep
adding new features,
you want to keep
making it better.
And that basically kicks
off this whole cycle again
of when you're considering
new features that you want
to beta test, that you
want a soft launch,
and eventually launch and so on.
OK, I'll start with
beta testing first.
More than 60% of the top
1,000 apps on Google Play
are running a beta
test right now.
This has been a very,
very popular tool.
We have heard really
great feedback
from developers about it.
You can run, as I
mentioned, closed beta test
with a very limited audience.
You can run open beta test with
a much wider audience where
it can get much more feedback.
I will not go into
details about how
each one of these work, what are
the different things about it,
what are the things
that are the same.
I will be doing office
hours later here today
and I'll be here
for all the days.
So if you have any
questions about that
I am more than happy to answer.
However, one thing that
I do want to talk about
is some of the
improvements we've
made to the beta testing in
the last couple of months.
One of those was
at I/O this year,
we've allowed users
to start opting
in to apps with open betas
from the Play Store itself.
So users can now discover
apps with open beta programs,
and they can opt in directly
from the Play Store.
This has proved to be that
very step that kind of removes
the churn of users
joining your beta test.
So many apps have
told us that they've
got 10x larger beta programs
as a consequence of making
this change.
Beta testing in that sense
becomes a very powerful
soft launch tool
where you can actually
get a meaningful number of users
using your app while it's still
in development.
And you can actually
get relevant KPIs.
You can work on
optimizing those KPIs
and really making them better.
So at the point when you launch
fully you're really ready.
Which is exactly
what we recommend.
We recommend if
you haven't tried
this we recommend you
try running an open beta
and getting users feedback
and really, really [INAUDIBLE]
and working on it.
It does help you get to
a higher quality build.
It helps you get better
product market fit,
and it helps you
fine tune your KPIs.
All the metrics that you
care about about your app
or your game.
One more thing that
we launched recently
is private feedback
from your beta testers.
Again, beta testers can
submit feedback directly
from the Play Store front.
However, don't worry, no
one else gets to see this.
It's just for you, you can
see it in Developer Console.
And these reviews don't
affect your average rating.
So it's a very safe
environment for you
to try out different things.
It's OK if not everything works.
It's better that you find out
about that during the beta test
than once you're launched
to everyone in production.
And another recent addition
to the beta testing program
is Early Access.
So this is a new
collection, which we are now
showing to users in a Play
Store Front, which features
interesting apps and games
that are still in development,
but that are running
an open beta that test.
Users can find them,
discover them there.
And then again,
this is another way
that's bringing people
who are interested--
especially those users
who are early adopters.
Who do want to try new things.
Who do want to be the first
ones to discover an app
and to use it.
They're the ones whose
feedback you can basically
get by being part of the
Early Access program.
If you do have an app coming out
soon, please do reach out to us
and mention that you would like
to be part of the Early Access
program.
We are actively
onboarding apps to it.
There are a couple of-- I
will not go into details--
but developers that have
been part of the Early Access
program so far
have shared really,
really good feedback with us.
They've told us that it really
helps them improve the quality.
Again, kind of
interate, try out a lot
of things in a very
nice and quick way.
And just a couple of notes.
My favorite feedback
was from Readfeed,
which is an online
book club which
was part of the first batch
of apps that were part
of the Early Access program.
So they've told us that
being part of Early Access
help them identify new markets.
So what are the different
things their app
could be doing to really
be useful for more users.
They told us that they
were able to identify
a number of different bugs,
a number of different feature
requests that users really want.
In addition they
were able to A/B test
various different
things within their app
before they launched
openly to everyone.
And then finally, they was
able to build a community
of very passionate users.
These early adopters
are users-- they
are the promoters for your app.
They are the community that
can really create a lot of buzz
about your app.
So this is another benefit
you can get from this.
And if all this wasn't
enough to convince you
that soft launching is a
really good thing to try out,
there are a few more things.
Sometimes we hear
feedback from developers
who say that they would
rather keep it close and tight
and then just do
a big bang launch.
Keep in mind that you
only get one chance
to make a first impression
with your users.
You obviously want to make
the right first impression.
And the other thing is
if you try out your app
just with ten or 15 users
before you actually launch it,
you risk those users,
being your friends,
maybe not being honest.
Or not telling you a lot
of the data driven stuff
of like how often they
use your app, how often
they're returning
to it and all that.
So definitely consider something
that's a little bit more
scaled before you actually
launch openly to everyone.
OK a couple of tips
on how to soft launch.
Closed beta would be
the first thing to do.
You want a smaller,
limited set of people.
You want to test all of the
proof of concept, the core game
mechanics, or the
core app flows,
there are important to you.
Basic user experience.
Obviously want to catch
the crudest of crashes.
And you want to get some open
ended feedback from your users.
As a second stage, consider
a soft launch that's
still kind of a bit limited.
You can do this limiting
by either choosing
a subset of countries, perhaps
the ones that have fewer users.
We hear very often that
developers do soft launch
in New Zealand, which is
kind of a good approximation
for big markets
like US or Europe.
But its still kind of
smaller in the size.
Or you can limit
based on the number
of devices, or languages,
or any different ways.
At that point you
can already start
to track the metrics
that you get.
So at this point you can
already start looking
at the actual data coming in.
And rather than trusting people
to write a couple of lines
of how they like your
app, you can actually
see are they using
it twice a day,
are they using it
for an hour a day.
Those are very useful signals.
And then as the final
stages before you launch,
you want to consider going open
beta to all the actual markets
where you're looking
to launch externally.
At this point, you should be
able to get sufficient data
to really make sure that
your game economy is working,
or that users are
using your app in a way
that you would like them to use.
OK so let's slot
in these two things
that we talked about into our
app lifecycle, or our launch
lifecycle.
So beta testing
and Early Access.
It's important to keep in
mind that they are useful all
throughout of your life cycle.
You want to use
them to soft launch,
you want to use them as your
launching for the first time
to everyone.
And then you want
to keep using them
after that to keep iterating
on all the new features
that you're building, and
to keep improving your app.
OK let's talk a
little bit about how
you can improve the quality
of your app early on.
Ellie has talked about
Firebase Test Lab,
so I'm going to keep
building on top of this.
I'm going to talk
a little bit more
about the pre-launch report.
Pre-launch report is powered
by Firebase Test Lab,
so all of the APKs that get
uploaded to alpha and beta
channel in Developer
Console automatically
get sent to Firebase Test Lab.
And we run a number of
monkey tests on them.
We try testing out
various different things.
And then based on that we
generate a report which
is shared with you within
an hour of you uploading
those APKs to Google
Play Developer Console.
The first thing that you want
to check out in the report
are crashes.
We will run the tests on a
couple of tens of devices.
This is generally
more than you can--
this probably more than
you can do yourself
while you're developing
all the time.
So it's quite useful it's
automatic, it's free,
so is a very nice cheap way
to detect these crashes early.
In particular, you do want to
catch these crashes before they
turn into one star reviews
everyone knows about them.
For every crash report, you will
be able to see a stack trace,
you'll be able to see
device metadata, and then
some kind of other metadata
about run and so on.
The other thing that's part
of the pre-launch report
are screenshots.
So as we do these monkey
tests on your APKs,
we take screenshots
all along the way,
and then we share
these screenshots
with you in Google Play
Developver Console.
This comes in
pretty handy to see
how your app looks on various
different device screen sizes
or DPI's or anything like that.
It also comes in
pretty handy, as you
can see in the highlighted
screen shot, for testing out
we try testing out a couple
of different languages.
And for example in
this screen shot
you can see that the German
translations are too long
and they make the UI kind
of overflow a little bit.
So you know again you want to
catch this before the app is
actually launched.
And then finally, we also share
security alerts about the APKs
that you just uploaded.
Obviously I know no one
here would upload security
vulnerability on purpose,
but it does happen sometimes
by mistake.
It also does happen if
you pull in a third party
SDK, for example ads
or analytics library.
These sometimes come in with
security vulnerabilities.
So again you want to find
out about this sooner
rather than later.
And a quote we got
from Flinc, who
were really happy with the
pre-launch report so far.
They're saying
that it helps them
test on way more devices
than they could afford
if they were to do it manually.
OK now let's look at
pre-launch report.
Again, just like beta
testing and Early Access,
it's sort of useful all
throughout your launch
lifecycle.
You want to try it early on.
It's never too early to
start getting this feedback.
You want to use it
as you're launching,
and you want to use it
once your app is alive.
Cool, let's talk a little bit
about analyzing, experimenting,
and optimizing.
The first rule that
I want to talk about
is user acquisition report.
User acquisition report
is a conversion funnel
that shows you how many
visitors to your store listing
you're getting,
how many of those
are turning into installers,
and then how many of those
are actually buying
something within your app,
and eventually
becoming repeat buyers.
You can also break
down this report
based on the acquisition source.
So whether this is
organic traffic that
came through the Play Store,
or whether this is paid traffic
that came through ads
or something like that.
As of fairly recently you can
also break down this report
by country so you can
see how your conver--
whether, for example, your
localizations are not great,
and you are not converting that
well in Asia compared to Europe
and so on.
And once you have this
data, obviously you'll
want to optimize.
Just having the data for its
own sake is not very useful.
The tool that fits in really
well with user acquisition
report and that will help you
optimize this kind of very
top of the funnel--
this kind of drop off
between number of
visitors and installers--
are store listening experiments.
This has been another tool
that has been very, very
successful so far.
Developers have told us
that they really like it.
Precisely because
when you optimize
the top of your funnel, you
make the whole funnel wider.
And basically it's more likely
that more users will eventually
also turn to buyers, and to
repeat buyers, and so on.
More than 70% the part of
our top developers use store
listing experiment.
It's a great number,
and I don't think
it's surprising given that
it's bringing results.
It's bringing you
better conversion rates,
and it's bringing
you more installers,
and that's precisely
what you want.
The other thing is
obviously the tool is free.
The only thing that you need
is a designer or a copywriter.
So someone who can
can actually work
with trying to optimize
your store listening
and trying to convert
more users for you.
I'm going to give you a lot of
examples about store listing
experiments.
I feel that's the best way to
show you how developers are
actually using it, to
give you ideas of what's
useful to try out and to test.
To start with,
here are Flaregames
who have run with a single icon
test for their "Royal Revolt
2."
They have managed to increase
user acquisition rate by 30%.
So this was a pretty good.
From one test being able to
increase number of installers
by that much.
Erepublik Public Lab is a
little bit on the other side.
For launch of "Age
of Lords" they
have run a string of
different experiments.
And they have ranged
from plus 5% to plus 29%.
Overall improvements to
their acquisition rate
were also pretty high.
That was really good.
Expedia is another
interesting example.
You would think Expedia is
a well-established brand
at this point, and that
experimenting with their assets
wouldn't be worth it.
That turned out
not to be the case.
They have managed to get their
global install rate are by 10%
by optimizing their assets.
So it's worth thinking
that if Expedia,
a well-established brand,
can do this then apps that
are very early in their life
cycle can do even better.
You can go with
the bolder changes,
you can try even more things,
and get even better results.
One of my favorites,
Spry Fox's Alphabear.
As you can see they have a
very unique visual style.
Very, very interesting, creative
vision for what they wanted to
do.
And yet they were able
to kind of experiment
with different icon types.
Icon is particularly
big for games.
Experimenting with
different types for games
is a really big thing.
They started with the
one on the far left.
And it turned out that
the one on the far right
is actually
converting 18% better.
So you know it's
worth experimenting
with a few of these
different ones.
Instacart had a
really great success
with experimenting with
their short description.
So just by changing
their short description
they managed to increase
their conversion rate by 14%.
And what we generally
found to work really well
is short and to the
point short descriptions
which explain the value
proposition of your app
in the shortest possible way.
So this is what we've seen
work very well consistently.
And Angry Birds went
to town with it.
They really went on the
story listening experiment's
bandwagon.
And they were testing for
Angry Birds "POP!" launch.
They were testing the icon
over, and over, and over again.
It keeps going.
Basically they were running
test, after test, after test.
And with each one they
were choosing a winner
and then trying out
even more variance.
I guess their designers were
having a lot of fun with this.
Until they ended up
with the one that
was in double-digit increase
compared to where they started.
So it's worth not
just testing once.
It's worth keeping the
iterations going and just
really keeping this
moving because there
seems to always be some
gains to be had in this area.
And the final one, I promise
this is the last example.
This is Mixi.
This one is interesting
because Mixi
is a very, very big
Japanese developer
but they were looking
to go into US.
They wanted to do to bring their
"Monster Strike" game into US.
However, they had a feeling
that the local taste of people
in the US would be different
to the local taste of people
in Japan.
So they wanted to make
sure that they really
match the local taste as
expressed in the store listing.
So they started iterating
on the featured graphic
and on the video.
Then went on to
iterate on the screen
shots, on the description,
and eventually on the icon.
Over the scope of
a couple of months,
they had managed to increase
their conversion rate by 68%.
By running of test after test
in a very scientific, very
methodical way,
very persistent way.
Two main takeaways from this
would be A, keep going at it.
Keep making changes
and keep testing.
And the other one will be yes,
users in different countries
have very different tastes.
Very different local flavor.
So your store listing
in Asia will probably
end up looking much
different, or should end up
looking much different, to
your store listing in Europe.
OK, a couple of best practices.
Test in multiple languages.
This is exactly what I
was telling you just now.
So it's worth trying
out different things
for different languages.
And, as of earlier
this year, you
can run multiple
tests in parallel,
in different languages.
So this can all be very
easy and efficient.
Iterate.
Keep at it.
If it looks like there is always
a next improvement to be had,
focus on one thing at a time.
Don't do icon and description
tests at the same time
because it's going to be hard
to know what actually worked.
So choose to optimize
the icon first
and then optimize
screenshots, or so on.
Try to come up with
some sort of hypothesis.
This is another thing
that we've heard
is-- do feel like
your icon is too busy,
or do you feel your
colors are too pale
or just-- if you
can try to come up
with some sort of
hypothesis, then
you can possibly
optimize in a better
way than just randomly trying
out different text or graphics.
Give it some time.
It takes time to reach
statistical significance
with these results.
We pay a lot of
attention to tell you
when we think the experiment
is done and ready.
But in general just giving
it more time is going to be--
you will be more
sure that it's going
to yield actual, good results.
And finally be bold.
Especially if you're early
in your startup's life,
try out a lot of
different things.
It's harmless and it's
cheap, so it's worth
playing around with a lot of
different visual identities.
OK and the last thing
related to localizing.
Earlier this year we've also
launched pricing templates.
Pricing templates allow
you to manage the pricing
for your entire app and
in a product catalog.
In a bulk way.
In a very easy, bulk way.
So if you haven't
switched to them yet--
many developers have-- but
if you haven't switched
to them yet, we
definitely recommend them
as a very efficient, bulk
pricing management tool.
However on top of that, when
we added pricing templates
we also added smart,
localized, price rounding.
So for example, if you
input your default price
and auto-convert to
all the 70 markets
to which Google Play now
sells, using the latest
the conversion rates we
will do the smart rounding.
So for example you don't end
up with 0.73 euros price,
you end up with 0.99.
Or you don't end up
with 182 Japanese yen,
we would round that
to 200 Japanese yen.
We came up with these smart,
locally relevant pricing
rounding rules.
So make sure you refresh
your prices to pick those up.
Your store listing
and your catalog
will look more professional
to users in those countries,
and it will also
look more relevant
for their local culture.
Let's slot a couple of these
tools in our life cycle
as well.
User aqcuisition tool-- sorry,
user acquisition reports
store listing
experiments, and pricing
templates-- all only valid
once you've fully launched.
These are the tools that require
you to have a lot of data
or certain amount of data
before you can work with them.
So you can only use
them once you launch
and once you keep
iterating on your app
once it's fully launched.
OK let's talk a little
bit about listening
to what your users are
really telling you,
and about interacting
with your users.
We've touched very briefly
on the private feedback
in the first section--
beta testing--
but let's say now
you're launched,
you're out to
everyone, and there
is a lot of feedback coming in.
What do you do with
all those feedback?
But before that, let me just
refer to two things that
may not be entirely obvious.
As you work on your app
quality, especially this quality
is reflected through your
average rating score,
you will actually also be
increasing your revenue.
This may not be
entirely obvious,
but the feedback we've heard
from a number of developers,
and the recent one
is from GameVille,
is that by bringing their app
from 3.3 stars to 4.1 stars
they've also increased
their revenue by 160%.
I mean this is
pretty good stuff.
So it's worth trying out.
The other thing that
totally may not be obvious,
is that by working
on your quality
through improving
the average rating,
you're actually also
working on your velocity.
Aviary shared very interesting
feedback with us recently.
What they started doing is
they start a staged rollout,
and then they start getting
a lot of feedback from users.
And they analyze
this feedback, which
allows them to cut their release
cycle to two to three weeks,
which they weren't
able to do before,
or they're not able to
do on other platforms.
So just by really shifting
your cycle-- your development
cycle-- to make addressing
reviews a core part of it,
you can osing increase your
velocity and ship faster.
In the past year we've
done a lot of improvements
to-- because we realize
ratings and reviews are
really important,
we've done a number
of improvements in the area.
Make sure to check them out
in the Google Play Developer
Console.
New user overhaul user ratings
section, overhaul user review
section, and a completely
new review analysis section
that I'll come back in a minute
and I'll talk a little bit more
about it.
But it's definitely
worth checking out
all the improvements
that are there.
Another thing that I'll
come back to a little bit
later is the new mobile--
the new Google Play Developer
Console mobile app
which we've launched.
But in this case I just
want to talk about it
very briefly in terms of how
it can help you manage customer
feedback and how it can help
with customer interaction
In the new mobile app obviously
you can see the latest reviews,
you can see the user rating,
you can see various breakdowns
and all of that.
But more importantly, you can
also interact with your users.
You can reply to user reviews
directly from the app.
Why that's important here is
because custom interaction
has this very important
time component.
So it's important to reply
to your user feedback
in a timely fashion.
And when you have Deveoper
Console App in your pocket,
this now becomes much easier.
You don't had to
go to your desk,
and type it in properly there.
The other thing that we've
launched with the app
is notifications.
So you can get notified when
users change their review
after your reply, or when
they post one star reviews,
or anything like
that you will really
like to react in a quick way.
And talking about
responding to user reviews,
this is starting
to be really big.
In the past year
we had 92% growth
in the number of
developer replies.
This is vastly bigger
than the organic growth
in number of apps, or organic
growth numbers of reviews
that are being posted.
So developers are really
picking up this practice
and they're really
starting to reply a lot.
So this is something
that's worth considering.
It does lead to to
higher average rating.
It does lead to users
feeling more appreciated.
So users are almost starting
to expect now that developers
will reply to their reviews.
OK so talking about
reviews, we've
recently launched
review analysis section.
There are a couple
of different things
where we really
work hard to help
you parse all this feedback and
analyze all this feedback you
get from developers.
One of those is highlights.
So we extract all the
relevant snippets and phrases
that users are
mentioning in your app,
and then we select them for
you in both Developer Console.
We also show these in
the Play storefront
So it's worth keeping an eye
on what we're showing you
in the storefront and checking
it out in Developer Console
as well.
The other thing we've launched
recently are review topics.
So again we do various machine
learning and natural language
processing to extract the topics
that we think are relevant,
and again, that users are
talking about when they write
reviews for your app.
So for example if you
are a language learning
app like the one
here, we would extract
all the various languages that
users are maybe asking for.
Or if you're a car
racing game, we
might be talking about various
different things about cars
or about racing and so on.
On top of that, you can actually
see how each one of those
topics-- what's the average
rating for reviews that mention
the topic, what's the
number of reviews,
and then also what is
the effect on the rating
that this topic has.
This basically tells you
what is the easy area
to focus on if you want
to improve something.
So here, for example,
we can immediately
tell that the fact that this
language learning app doesn't
have support for
klingon is causing
like a lot of negative reviews
The other thing that we
have launched recently,
also part of review
analysis, was benchmarks.
So we identified
eight characteristics
that every app has.
Those eight are things
like design, speed,
stabilty, and so on.
For each one of
those eight, again we
show you based on your
user reviews, what
is the average rating-- what
is the sentiment of users
with regard to this
particular benchmark.
And then we also
show you how your app
compares on this particular
aspect to other similar apps.
Apps in the same
category, or apps
that are in the same
monetization model,
or something like that.
And then we'll show
you effect on rating.
Is design a big
plus of your app,
or is speed a big
minus and so on.
And then finally for
one interesting point
about the analysis.
We also analyze the complete
corpus of all the ratings
and reviews on Google Play.
There is a lot of them.
One interesting thing
that we found out
is that the majority, or
50%, of all one star ratings
mention or are related
to stability and bugs.
And then 65% of all
five star ratings
are related to speed,
design, or usability.
So it's important
keeping in mind
what is the thing that's
actually driving the rating up,
and what is the
thing that's actually
driving the rating down.
What are the things that users
are really irritated with,
and what are the things that
users are really happy about.
A very brief mention for
also our new reviews API.
If you want automated way to
fetch your reviews from Google
Play, and to reply to them,
we now have an API for that.
It's only a couple of lines
of code integrated with it.
Super easy.
However if you would
rather not do that,
there is also out of
the box integration
with some popular
customer relationship
management tools, like Zendesk
and [INAUDIBLE] Social.
So if you would like a
more integrated approach
to managing your
customer feedback,
we have a way to
do that as well.
OK let's lot in these two
tools as well-- reviews
analysis and review API.
They're very useful,
not in this first stage
as you are launching your
app for the first time,
but they become absolutely
critical at the point when
your app is live, and you're
receiving all the feedback
from users, and you want
to keep working on it
and keep improving your app.
OK the last thing, monitoring
your app on the go.
As I mentioned, we launched
the Play Console app at IO
this year and then
in the best kind
of way of doing what
we're preaching here,
we've also done a fast follower
release a couple of weeks
later.
This fast follower
obviously included
a number of stability
fixes, but it also
included a number
of new features
that you guys told us would be
really good to have in the app.
It included review
notifications,
being able to manage store
listing experiments directly
from the app, being able to
increase the staged rollout
or to hold a bad staged
rollout out of your app.
If you still haven't
tried yet, please do.
Send us feedback.
We're reading it.
We're actually reading it.
We are trying really
hard to address it,
and we want to keep adding new
features to the Play Console
app.
And one more mention of
another app that we have,
which is Playbook for
developers, for you guys.
This is the perfect place
to keep getting insights
about what's new
in Google Play--
to find out about new features,
to get the best practices,
to get tips and tricks, and
in general a lot of advice
on what is the best way
to succeed on Google Play.
Slotting these two in, we
think both Play Console app
and Playbook app would be useful
all throughout your launch life
cycle.
So make sure you try them out.
And I think that's everything
I wanted to cover today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]